(crowd applauding and cheering)
- [Drew] Right here in Hollywood
and all week long,
we're kicking off today's show
with a very special performance.
Featuring dancers from
Hollywood, California,
Adel Carerra founded the
nonprofit: Dance Engagements.
As a way to empower dance enthusiasts
of all ages shapes and sizes.
I love them and they're here!
(crowd applauding and cheering)
Take it away!
(upbeat dance music)
(crowd applauding and cheering)
- [Drew] I am so honored
that you're here today,
and I want to share something with you.
I- my mom was one of those moms
who put me in like tap, jazz, ballet.
And I really did not feel
like I fit in anywhere.
Then there was a dance
troop, but funny enough,
the teacher was really
tough on all the girls
who weren't tall and skinny.
I'm just going to say it out loud.
And I felt like an outcast
and I didn't feel good about myself.
Until my mom took me to karate.
(laughter)
(crowd applauding and cheering)
I found something and that might've been
seeds for something like Charlie's Angels.
(crowd applauding and cheering)
- [Drew] Because I felt good about the way
that I was made and who I
was and I found my people.
So I want to ask you, Adel,
What made you change the system
and help people not feel
like I did when I was a kid?
- [Adel] Right.
Well, I think dance is a
very intimidating community.
- [Drew] Yes.
- So it it's important to
display for our mission,
that all ages and sizes
are capable of dancing.
And everyone should have-
(crowd applauding and cheering)
- [Adel] And anyone should
have access to dance.
(crowd applauding and cheering)
- [Drew] I'm watching you guys
and every single one of
you has got the moves.
You are so money!
Who inspires you as a dancer, may I ask?
- Growing up, definitely
my biggest inspiration,
definitely hands down, Missy Elliott.
(crowd applauding and cheering)
She was someone who did
not have backup dancers.
She was a dancer.
She engaged, she fully did choreo.
And it gave me that inspiration
of like, I can do that too.
- Yeah. She is such an inspiration.
She really is.
Well, Missy Elliott actually heard
about what you've been doing
and she has a special message for you.
- Hey, Adel, It is Missy
misdemeanor Elliot!
And I just want to say `first
of all, congratulations.
I love what you are doing
with Dance Engagements and all the dances.
And I know it's going
to continue to grow big
and I can't wait.
I'm going to be right
here to cheer you on.
And I heard that I inspire
you, but guess what?
You inspire me.
And I want you to continue
to do what you doing.
It's amazing.
I love you!
(crowd applauding and cheering)
- It looks like you might inspire
someone that inspired you.
How great does that feel?
- That's wild.
- [Drew] I know!
- I just want to thank
you guys for coming today.
I'd also want to donate $10,000 to your-
(crowd applauding and cheering)
amazing school from me.
Let this be the beginning of a
beautiful friendship support.
Go to the drewbarrymoreshow.com
to learn more
about Adel's program and thank you
to the choreographing
duo Tyrell and Latrina!
(crowd applauding and cheering)
Who have choreographed
for artists, you know.
They've choreographed for some people
called Beyonce and Justin
Timberlake and Mariah Carey.
So thank you, you guys so much, so much!
(crowd applauding and cheering)
Thank you. Thank you.
(upbeat music)